and a reward is increased for  information leading to the arrest of a  fugitive the eight news now i-team first  told us about william mize is wanted for  staging car accidents ripping off  insurance companies and running a major  crime ring the u.s marshals say he was  last seen in henderson and he considers  himself the godfather of a white collar  crime family one of his prized  possessions his now deceased pet a jet  setting chihuahua decked out in jewels  the reward is now ten thousand dollars  up from 2500 if you have information  about the whereabouts of william myes  call the marshals the info to do so is  on 8newsnow.com along with the i-team's  full report